Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Arrow we got our first official look at
the Suicide Squad.
The writers have big plans for them that include
the battle against Deathstroke this season
and stuff happening in season 3.
I’ll talk about all that and what’s going
on in the next couple of episodes.
I’ve even got some cool details on the Flash
crossover that’s coming.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Arrow and Flash videos every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Tomorrow I’ll be posting a Q&A video, so
be sure to write any questions you want me
to include in the comments.
So now let’s talk about our Top 5 moments
from the episode, then I’ll do some of my
favorite references to the comic books and
my review.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Here we go, Number 5 - Oliver’s Awful Home
Movies.
In keeping with the theme of the episode Oliver
steps into the killbox that is Slade’s office.
Felicity dropped the “suicide” reference.
Just tying it to the Suicide Squad A-story.
I loved how you could just tell Slade was
setting the table for Oliver so to speak.
A buffet of death with an appetizer of awful
memories.
It’s almost like this is Hannibal and Oliver
is Will Graham, being framed for murder by
Hannibal Lecter played by Slade.
Shows within shows.
I always love scenes where characters sit
and watch movies.
In this case there wasn’t really any subtext
to the Shado movie, it was just Slade making
Oliver think about her.
I wonder how many other awful home movies
Slade has collected.
He strikes me as the kind of obsessive person
who would also just sit there and watch Shado
on a loop all night.
When he wasn’t busy watching Oliver’s
house on a loop.
Number 4 - Diggle and Deadshot’s heart to
heart.
Not an action scene, but full of action.
This was a really good moment for anyone who
hasn’t read the comics.
Essentially of all the Suicide Squad members,
Deadshot is the closest to being a good person.
Or a good person who does really bad things.
I loved that he said the drone strike was
his way out.
I think they were misleading us a little.
He probably expected to escape at the last
second and just let them believe he was dead.
A character that proficient doesn’t lose
the will to live just because he’s working
with Amanda Waller.
Maybe she just sucks the life out you with
those cold stares.
And that’s her superpower.
Diggle’s arc in the episode was recognizing
the grey area, which is what the Suicide Squad
is all about.
Just like the Thunderbolts in the Marvel universe,
I don’t think they ever really get rehabilitated.
They’ll always be villains.
But that’s why it’s so much cooler when
you see them team up with heroes.
And in case you missed it, that last scene
with Amanda Waller and Oliver is a teaser
for a future episode.
They’ll be helping Oliver take down Slade.
Number 3 - We’ve been tracking a new player.
We’re calling him Deathstroke.
It’s a little crazy that Amanda Waller with
all her resources, doesn’t know Slade is
the Deathstroke they’ve been tracking.
They kind of buried the lead a little, but
in that moment, Waller basically gave Slade
his callsign.
I know Billy Winters wore the mask in season
1, but did any of the characters ever use
the name Deathstroke?
I can’t remember.
This whole exchange with Waller is really
just an awesome teaser for Oliver co-opting
the Squad to take down Slade in a future episode.
We don’t know when they’re going to be
back, I would guess that it’s going to either
be in episode 18 called Deathstroke or in
one of the final episodes.
There will be 23 total, but we only have details
up to episode 20.
The other thing I thought was really interesting
about this ARGUS scene was that it gives you
the sense that something even bigger than
the Oliver VS Slade battle is coming.
Like that’s not even the biggest moment
that’s coming this season.
I talked about how Manu Bennett was teasing
Ra’s Al Ghul in a previous video.
I can’t quite remember which one it was,
but I have a playlist link at the end of this
video.
So you can scan through all my Arrow Season
2 stuff if you want the details on that.
Long story short.
The conflict between Slade and Oliver is going
to cause so much damage that Ra’s Al Ghul
will come to deal with it.
Number 2 - Meet Task Force X
So this is the suicide squad.
But Task Force X is a big comic book reference
to an organization consisting of Checkmate,
The Suicide Squad and Argent.
It was created to fill the void left by the
Justice Society when they retired.
This all happened back in the 80s.
The thing that really got me excited about
them was that because the show has made it
official.
They can start developing the team and use
them even more in season 3.
The showrunners said that they have this mutli-season
approach to developing those characters and
the team.
Jut like they’re doing with The Birds of
Prey starting in next week’s episode.
Think of this episode as the teaser for future
Suicide Squad episodes.
And if they’re really successful, they might
even spin off Suicide Squad like they’re
doing for The Flash.
That’s a long ways off, so don’t plan
on seeing any more Arrow spinoffs for a long
time.
The Flash still hasn’t even been given a
series order yet.
But there is a lot more Suicide Squad coming,
later this season and next season.
and my number 1 moment - Do you cuties need
help, I’m a trained therapist.
And with just a few lines, we get one of the
biggest teasers all season long.
Meet Harley Quinn, core member of The Suicide
Squad and a backdoor to the Batman Universe.
Don’t expect the Joker anytime soon or Nightwing
for that matter.
But it’s possible that we’ll actually
be seeing her character the next time the
Suicide Squad is featured this season.
The funny thing is that they listed her in
the credits as “Deranged Team Member”.
Which means they didn’t want to do an official
reveal yet.
Why that is, I have no idea.
But a lot of people thought Cassidy Alexa
was actually playing her.
But Tara Strong was listed as the voice in
the credits.
It’s possible that they just dubbed her
over Cassidy Alexa.
Tara Strong has done the voice for Harley
in all the Batman Arkham video games for the
last couple of years.
So they really did go to the source for authenticity.
It would have been funny if they had used
the original voice from the animated series,
but I can totally understand them wanting
to use someone who is currently voicing the
character.
In one of my earlier videos I talked about
Chekov’s Gun.
It’s the idea that you never include something
unless you’re going to pay it off later
in the story.
Never make a promise you don’t intend to
keep.
Since they gave us Harley Quinn’s voice,
it’s like promising us that she’ll be
on the show at some point.
So we will get to see her full on, soon.
No confirmation on which episode though.
But bet on it being the next time the Suicide
Squad is featured.
Now it’s your turn though, let me know what
you’re favorite moment was.
Harley Quinn, I know.
We’re all thinking the same thing.
So here’s a couple really big comic book
references and funny things from the episode
before I do my review.
First, Felicity had a stalker in college.
This was just hilarious.
2 - Diggle’s Booty Call, during which we
find out Amanda Waller has also used the Argus
suite for her own Booty Calls in the past.
This is even funnier if you know the comic
book version of her character.
3 - The khandaq name drop is a reference to
Black Adam.
They haven’t introduced the idea of Magic
on Arrow in a big way, but this makes it seem
like they will in a distant season.
Like season 5 or beyond.
Billy Batson cameo anyone?
4 - Ben Browder Backdoor Cameo again as Ted
Gaynor from the comics.
5 - Another shout out to Lyla Michaels Harbinger
character from the comics.
Lyla in the comics was given huge superpowers
by the Monitor during the big Crisis on Infinite
Earths storyline back in the 80s.
and last one number 6 - Several shout outs
to Deadshot’s daughter Zoe Lawton from the
comics.
Overall I gave the episode a B plus, just
because it was so much fun and they were able
to use all these characters without the story
collapsing under the weight.
It was a really good dark Arrow story.
You have all these villains so naturally it
made sense for Oliver to be really dark.The
writers are doing a really good job of bringing
all the different storylines this season together
for this big Deathstroke battle.
But remember, that’s not even the biggest
thing that’s going to happen.
There’s the threat of Ra’s Al Ghul, just
casting a shadow over Slade.
That’s why Arrow has become one of my favorite
shows this year.
It just keeps unvieling bigger and bigger
threats.
Right now Agents of SHIELD has the clairvoyant.
But in order to match Arrow, they’d have
to reveal an A-List supervillain behind the
clairvoyant.
Let me know what you thought of the episode
and remember, Birds of Prey next week.
Be sure to subscribe to get my video.
My Q&A video for this will post tomorrow.
So leave me all your questions.
Right now click here to learn more about The
Flash and Click here to learn all about Avengers
2.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!